so charlie cox is back
playing daredevil in spider-man 3
spider-man 3 i think it's how you
pronounce that
i'm pretty sure that's how you pronounce
that look at this place it's all
decorated
for halloween i'm watching the chef show
on netflix hopefully uh netflix and
copyright strike this
um that's amazing that's absolutely
amazing the charlie cox is coming back
as daredevil
and here's the thing i'm glad that's
happening because i'll be honest with
you guys
i know that like there was a big pissing
match between feige
and jeff loeb uh with jeff loeb taking
the tv side feige taking the movie side
it was kind of like well you know that's
why we're gonna refer to the avengers
movie as
the event you know and all that kind of
stupid stuff i'm glad to see
that like at least one guy is running
the show and those characters are
getting rolled in
honestly as excited as i am for charlie
cox
um i'm more excited for like vincent
d'onofrio to return as the kingpin
and uh john bernthal to come back as the
punisher
because i don't think vincent d'onofrio
died right kingpin didn't die
in the uh in the netflix tv series did
he like i'm pretty sure he's still alive
and john bernthal was an amazing
punisher here's the thing i would love
to see john bernthal come back as a
punisher to like face off against the
new avengers or something like that
uh it'd be awesome like it was because
the punishers had so many great moments
like when he saved spider-man's life in
civil war
like he saved him from being killed in
the sewers of new york and then shows
him on a doorstep
of captain america like captain
america's secret avengers and
uh and it's like dude like like medic
you know he comes busting in he's like
medic so they bring in some people to
take care of spider-man
and then you end up finding out that
captain america's allied himself with
villains
so like these villains come in and
they're like we're here to help you cap
and the punisher just sprays him down
he doesn't say anything he just unloads
on him and captain america freaks out
he's like you murderous son of a bee
and just starts attacking him he's like
there are bad guys cat
he just killed him on the spot didn't
even give him a chance to explain
it was pretty it was it's not funny it's
hilarious it's
it was hilarious but uh but no i'm
excited for charlie cox
and that's the thing man like the cast
the casting just keeps coming out and
out and out for spider-man 3 right like
like what is it we have uh what's his
name coming back um
what a alfred molina whatever his name
is coming back from uh
from the old spider-man 2 sony movies to
play doctor octopus again
i want to see superior spider-man son i
want to see superior spider-man i want
to see him take over the body of peter
parker
and like become the become like the
superior spider-man and then become a
better spider-man than peter parker was
dude superior spider-man was amazing
there's this point in the story
when dr octopus when he's in possession
of peter parker's body he goes to fight
the scorpion and punches the bottom half
of his jaw off
and then he's like holy cow spider-man's
been pulling his punches all these years
it's the craziest thing it's one of the
coolest things but uh but no charlie
cox's daredevil
he was he was incredible right daredevil
was obviously the standout show on
netflix
it was an amazing show i'm glad to see
that it's coming back
i'm glad to see that charlie cox is
reprising the character that we all love
him for because
and if i'm being honest i can't really
see anybody else besides ben affleck
just kidding i can't see anybody else
playing daredevil besides charlie cox at
this point like it's just
it's it's he just did that good of a job
right then you throw him in with like
tom holland
and you you throw a man with with molina
and you throw him in with like was it
we're getting andrew garfield and we're
getting tobey maguire
in the spider-man movies i mean this is
kind of crazy man
like i have no idea what all this means
i mean i assume that there's going to be
some multiversal travel going on
otherwise
how do you explain their existence
unless like you know doctor strange is
like hey man count yourself
lucky with your identity being out cut
yourself lucky here's a spider-man you
could have been
and then shows them like toby mcguire
and andrew garfield and tom holland's
like
no
it'd be hilarious but uh but nonetheless
i'm very very excited i am very very
excited for for
for this whole revelation um here's the
thing and i've been telling people this
for for
years and years and years i've been
telling people this for a long long time
people
like like the marvel cinematic universe
what we've seen is the tip of the
iceberg
everything that's happened in the last
six and last 10 years in the marvel
cinematic universe
for all you non-comic book readers out
there this is a 12
issue story for us right like that's
that's what this is right this is just a
maxi series right
maybe a little bit bigger if you want to
throw in a few tie-ins and you can make
each individual
general individual film its own comic so
okay like a 22-23 issue long
long thing right like there are whole
runs of characters that span hundreds of
issues just to give you guys perspective
right like
the original civil war story was over
100 issues long like
just to give you guys perspective here
right the same thing with like avengers
versus
x-men it was like 120 issues long it was
crazy the old annihilation including the
times i think was actually a little bit
shorter
annihilation conquest was a lot bigger
uh but
you know this is the tip of the iceberg
like marvel has barely even begun to
approach
the possibility of even thinking about
the idea
of getting into like the meat and
potatoes of everything they could do
like there's so much that could be
enough so what are you doing
look look at my dog this dog star what
are you doing
what do you want girl she's gotta miss
piggy with her what do you want star
she was she was i posted on instagram on
my personal instagram i am rob jefferson
i posted up there she uh she drug big
dirty
out of mariah's office and was laying on
it in the hallway right big dare big
dirty is the name of the big teddy bear
we have
we were going through walmart and i saw
this giant teddy bear that i wanted to
get mariah so i bought it
and uh and we and i called it big dirty
so that's the name of it now
big dirty the teddy bear but uh but yeah
you know this is this is kind of wild
so to celebrate this monumentous moment
to celebrate this monumentous moment um
we're gonna sell some rob core rings
again yes we are but i've also got merch
i've also got like t-shirts and stuff
like that i've got four design four
four rod core t-shirt designs so you'll
find the t-shirts
and the rod core rings down in the
description um i want to i want to kind
of put those on sale now so that if
anybody orders them you can get them in
time for christmas
some of you guys bought them for like
you were buying them like two or three
at a time right buy them ones for like
yourself and like your girlfriend or
your girlfriend was buying it for like
herself and you or
whatever the case was and people were
was it somebody bought it for like their
younger brother
right so we had people who were buying
like two or three at a time uh but last
last time we did this they they sold out
in two hours
so um you better be fast because they're
gonna go
quick but anyway guys that's not to say
all the people who were following the
the the store on etsy uh because that's
where they get sold start what are you
doing
why are you parking they get sold on
etsy and there are people who are
following the store so as soon as they
go live they're immediately on there and
they start they start buying them up so
you better be quick you better be super
quick because it's going to be 20 of
each size the same time we did last time
same thing we did last time um there
will also be a size 12 out this time
around so
uh so yeah it's kind of wild kind of
crazy
uh but very very very very cool all
these different castings
that are going out now like it's it's
really wild like i'm very excited about
this
so anyway guys uh we'll go ahead and
wrap this video up
uh thank you guys for watching and i
just want to say this this is
it's a great time to be a comic book fan
right it's a great time to be a comic
book fan
now i guess all we're really waiting for
here is venom to be rolled over into the
mcu
i guess is all we're really waiting for
is venom to be brought over into the
marvel cinematic universe
uh and it's all just kind of coming
together and it's being cohesive right
it's getting getting more and more
cohesive so
uh high times ahead of us folks i will
say i think spider-man 3 is going to
have
massive ramifications for the future of
the mcu with different movies that we're
going to see
and all that kind of stuff i feel like
it's going to have massive ramifications
we're going to see
a whole bunch of stuff coming out of it
probably x-men probably fantastic for
some things like that
i wouldn't be surprised if like there's
some throwaway scene where peter parker
gets an invitation to the future
foundation and throws it away
future foundation of course is a
fantastic four founded by reed richards
it's like their own think tank kind of
thing
uh it's cool right so i'm very very
excited i am very very hyped
uh this is huge news so anyway guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an
end and i will catch you all later peace